most of you two-thirds of you in here
are going to become
consultants and you will never make any
decisions of
consequence and there's nothing wrong
with that Pursuit if you want to be
irrelevant because you will be within
two years I never hire Consultants
because they've never managed anything
their opinions are valuable people pay
for them but they've never ever made a
decision of consequence and they haven't
learned much either they keep hopping
from one sectoral business to another
and they live their lives in mediocrity
well-paid mediocrity but I can't say
enough bad stuff about it hi Mr
Wonderful here and I am small business
does your company qualify for the
employee retention credit find out at
Wonder trust.com educate yourself with a
live expert at Wonder trust now because
the ERC program is going to end soon